The first motorist to be fined for speeding
in the UK was Walter Arnold in 1896.
He was doing 8 mph in a 2 mph zone.
The average person who lives to be 75 will
have spent six years dreaming.
In the first month of its life, a silkworm
puts on 10,000 times its birth weight.
During World War II, the crew of the British
submarine HMS Trident kept a fully grown reindeer
called Pollyanna aboard their vessel for six
weeks (it was a gift from the Russians).
In 1999, a four-year-old girl turned yellow
after drinking too much Sunny Delight.
Young Neanderthal girls had bigger biceps
than an adult male human.
25 million Bibles were printed in 2011, compared
to 208 million IKEA catalogues.
The longest hangover in medical literature
lasted four weeks.
It belonged to a 37-year-old man from Glasgow.
The katzenklavier or “cat piano”, was
a musical instrument made out of cats.
Designed by 17th-century German scholar Athanasius
Kircher, it consisted of a row of caged cats
with different voice pitches, who could be
“played” by a keyboardist driving nails
into their tails.
The ties bought in America for Father's Day
each year would stretch from New York to Rome.
The Vatican City has the highest crime rate
in the world in comparison to its population.
Though the resident population is only just
over 800, more than 600 crimes are committed
there each year.
Diagnosed with pleurisy, Sir Robert Chesebrough,
the inventor of Vaseline, decided to coat
himself in his product from head to foot.
He survived and lived to be 96.
The world's lightest metal is 100 times lighter
than styrofoam and can rest on a dandelion
puff without damaging it.
The symbols used by cartoonists to indicate
swearing are called grawlixes.
Male fruit flies rejected by females drink
significantly more alcohol than those that
have had a successful mating encounter.
Light doesn't always travel at the speed of
light.
The slowest we've ever recorded light traveling
at is 38mph.